[Music]
Karrie why is your tour starting in May
[Music]
Oh baby Carrie Underwood is expecting
her second child with husband Mike
Fisher the country crooner took to
Instagram Wednesday morning to share a
bundle of info with her followers
including details on her cry pretty tour
360 and the sweet announcement was the
real surprise Mike and Isaiah and I are
absolutely over the moon and excited to
be adding another little fish to our
pond I this this is just been a dream
come true with album and with baby news
and all that stuff we're just so excited
and just so glad that you guys can
sharing this with us and be a part of
this with us Carrie didn't reveal any
other details like her due date but her
pink metallic jacket caused fans to
speculate over the gender of baby number
two I'm carrying around a little bit of
extra weight while she was pregnant with
her now three-year-old son back in 2014
the singer told ET the couple would love
to try for a girl someday we plan on
having a girl I don't know if you can do
that but at some point we'd really like
that
[Applause]
you